die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend schön dass
Sie dabei sind wie auch Norbert Lehmann
für den Sport
der umfangreichste warnsteig seit 30
Jahren
Stillstand mit Ansage der Warnstreik von
Verdi und EVG legt vieles lahm das ganz
großes Chaos bleibt aber aus
weiterer Gesprächsbedarf nach einer
langen Nacht vertagt sich der
ampelkoalitionsausschuss auf morgen um
inhaltliche Streitfragen zu klären
Israel am Scheideweg die Justizreform
spaltet das Land immer weiter jetzt hat
die Regierung reagiert
[Musik]
fünf Stunden noch dann ist es vorbei um
Mitternacht endet der 24-stündige
wagenstreik Millionen mussten umplanen
und haben das offenbar auch getan die
Straßen waren weniger voll als
befürchtet fast schon Gespenste still
war es an vielen Flughäfen das gleiche
Bild an deutschen Bahnhöfen komplett
ohne Fernverkehr in sieben Bundesländern
wurde auch der Nahverkehr bestreicht
überrascht davon zeigten sich heute die
wenigsten Stefan Schlösser berichtet
gähnende Leere am Vormittag im
Frankfurter Hauptbahnhof wo sonst
hunderttausende jeden Tag unterwegs sind
dafür Andrang bei den Fernbussen Schüler
und Schülerinnen auf Klassenfahrt nach
Amsterdam haben kurzerhand umgebucht wir
werden schon alle gerne lieber mit dem
Zug gefahren aber ja ich glaube wir
machen alles besser draußen nichts los
auch an den großen deutschen Flughäfen
allein in Frankfurt fallen über 1100
Flüge aus wer nicht rechtzeitig vor
Streik Beginn einen Anschluss bekommen
hat hängt erstmal fest
wir werden jetzt mit dem Bus
weitergefahren nach Paderborn und
fliegen dann von Paderborn nach Gran
Canaria auch weite Teile des
öffentlichen Nahverkehrs stehen still im
sächsischen Plauen kommt heute keine
Straßenbahn wer darauf angewiesen ist
hat extra Stress weil man muss das halt
dann auch irgendwie
alles managen ne das ist Zeit technische
schafft dann schaffst es nicht zur
Arbeit ja weil du musst ja auch
irgendwie gucken dass sie die Kinder
alle holst und wegbringst und schwer
heute
voll war es teilweise morgens auf den
Straßen wenn Homeoffice nicht möglich
ist dann bleibt für viele nur das Auto
wie geht es Ihnen jetzt heute mit diesem
Streik ja es ist auf einer dieses
wichtig und aber andersrum ist heute zu
arbeiten die Bahngewerkschaft IVG macht
gemeinsame Sache mit Verdi zwei
Gewerkschaften doppelte Streit macht die
Bahner fordern 12% mehr Lohn mindestens
aber ein Plus von 650 €. wir haben die
Gewerkschaft EVG aufgefordert schnell an
den Verhandlungstisch zurückzukehren es
ist sehr befremdlich dass man heute
streikt und erst in fünf Wochen bereit
ist wieder mit uns zu verhandeln doch
für Verhandlungen gebe es noch keine
ausreichende Grundlage kritisiert die
Gewerkschaft wir brauchen um an den
Tisch zu kommen einfach handlungsfähiges
Angebot um in der Tarif
Auseinandersetzung dann wirklich
konstruktiv am Tisch sitzen zu können
und auch zu einem Ergebnis kommen zu
können Millionen Reisen und Pendler
hoffen vor allem auf schnelle Ergebnisse
und keine weiteren Streiks
also von den zwei beteiligten
Gewerkschaften verhandelt die
Bahngewerkschaft EVG erst in ein paar
Wochen ver.di dagegen seit heute in
Potsdam in der dritten Verhandlungsrunde
mit so wörtlich ordentlich Druck auf dem
Kessel es geht um insgesamt 2,5
Millionen Beschäftigte im öffentlichen
Dienst dazu gehören Angestellte von
Kitas der Müllabfuhr oder Kliniken für
all diese Gruppen fordert Verdi nach wie
vor 10,5% mehr Geld mindestens aber 500
€ pro Monat das Gegenangebot von Bund
und Kommunen zuletzt fünf Prozent plus
Einmalzahlung und ein höheres
Weihnachtsgeld Nikola Albrecht
beobachtet die Verhandlungen in Potsdam
für uns Nicola zeigt dieser Warnstreik
schon Wirkung
nun ja konkrete Ergebnisse gibt es noch
nicht aber man kann sagen dass ein
Streik dieser Dimension schon den Druck
im verhandlungskessel hier hinter mir
noch einmal deutlich erhöht in einer
Verhandlungspause haben die Arbeitgeber
durchblicken lassen und das ziemlich
zähneknirschend dass man auf jeden Fall
weitere Streiks verhindern will doch
trotz aller Muskel und macht Spiele und
Demonstrationen heute verlief der erste
Verhandlungstag insgesamt doch ganz
schön bunt und Kommunen haben noch
einmal auf klammer Kassen verwiesen und
Verdi behaart auf den bekannten
Forderungen Annäherung Fehlanzeige
insofern erwarte ich hier auch keine
schnelle Einigung sondern noch zwei
weitere eher lange und Zähne
Verhandlungstage danke schön für diese
Informationen aus Potsdam Nicola
Albrecht war das
die verschiedenen Perspektiven dieses
Arbeitskampfes und wie die Menschen den
Streiktag erlebt haben all das
beleuchtet wieso direkt nach uns
jetzt zur Regierung und ihrem Streit um
klimaschutzpläne und Geld die Spitzen
der Koalition tackten die ganze Nacht
durch bis heute am frühen Nachmittag
fast 20 Stunden lang doch die Kuh ist
noch nicht vom Eis die Gespräche sind
unterbrochen weil die halbe Mannschaft
nach Rotterdam zur niederländischen
Regierung musste weg
der Verkehrsminister im
regierungshubschrauber Minuten nachdem
die Gespräche unterbrochen worden waren
aus dem Fenster zu sehen gibt es hier
wenig zu reden mit der Außenministerin
daneben noch weniger das Schweigen der
Ampel politisch gefundenes Fressen für
die Opposition
es ist nicht solide vorbereitet gewesen
oder die Gräben sind so tief dass man
gar nicht mehr zueinander findet die
Bürger erwarten Ergebnisse und das kann
die ampelregierung momentan überhaupt
nicht liefern ich finde angesichts der
gewaltigen Herausforderungen die wir in
unserem Land haben gigantische Inflation
diverse Probleme die anstehen ist das
unverantwortlich dass die Bürgerinnen
und Bürgern so gar nichts präsentiert
wird Zwischenstation auf dem
militärischen Teil des Berliner
Flughafens der Kanzler und das halbe
Kabinett beim Umsteigen es geht zur
Regierungskonsultationen in den
Niederlanden sichtlich bemüht und Bilder
die harmonisch wirken sollen nach der
Landung in Rotterdam setzt der Kanzler
das mit Worten fort
die Gespräche die wir bisher geführt
haben sehr vertraulich sehr freundlich
miteinander sind eine gute Grundlage um
sie dann morgen fest vorzusetzen und für
viele derjenigen die da jetzt in Berlin
im Kanzleramt zusammengesessen haben ist
es auch eine ganz nette Unterbrechung
dass wir uns jetzt hier gemeinsam
wiederfinden in Niederlanden um jetzt
mit unseren guten Freunden hier über
Europa und die Zukunft zu sprechen
morgen früh geht's in Berlin weiter wie
auch immer
ja Theo in Berlin die Koalitionspartner
scheinen sich da ziemlich verhakt zu
haben ja das kann man wohl laut sagen
auch wenn natürlich alle drei Parteien
inklusive Kanzler nach außen tapfer auf
die Zähne beißen und von
vertrauensvollen und konstruktiven
Gesprächen reden aber de facto ist die
Koalition an einem Punkt an dem man
quasi ohne Betäubung auf den Blank
liegenden Nerven des jeweils anderen
bohrt das erste regierungsjahr das war
ja geprägt von Kriegs und
Krisenbewältigung jetzt aber geht es an
die Kernthemen dieser Koalition und da
zeigt sich insbesondere beim Klima wie
weit die politischen Positionen
auseinander liegen soweit ich höre
verstehen die Grünen auf einer
Gegenleistung für Ihr Einverständnis zu
einem zwar begrenzten aber weiteren
autobahnenausbau dafür müsste sich im
Verkehrsbereich von Herrn wissigen die
Klimabilanz verbindlich verbessern FDP
und SPD aber halten offensichtlich
dagegen und diese kernkonfrontation die
ist beinhart auch nach einer
durchgearbeitet nachts und morgen früh
um 9 heißt es dann wieder Kampf im
Kanzleramt Runde 2 Dankeschön nach
Berlin
18 Leopard 2 Kampfpanzer und 40 Marder
Schützenpanzer hatte Deutschland der
Ukraine zugesagt jetzt sind sie dort
angekommen das hat der Bundeskanzler in
Rotterdam bestätigt der genaue
Transportweg blieb aus
Sicherheitsgründen geheim um die
Lieferung war monatelang gerungen worden
bis die Regierung Ende Januar zusagte
die Leopard Panzer gelten als mit die
modernsten überhaupt
der Weg Finnlands in die NATO scheint
nun so gut wie frei am Abend hat das
Parlament Umgangs mit großer Mehrheit
das beitrittsprotokoll für Finnland
ratifiziert zuvor hatte auch der
türkische Präsident Erdogan grünes Licht
gegeben alle übrigen 28 nato-
und jetzt nach Israel hat das taumelt
gerade in eine ernsthafte Staatskrise
Millionen Israelis sehen ihre Demokratie
in akuter Gefahr seit Wochen
protestieren hunderttausende gegen die
geplante Justizreform mit ihr will
Ministerpräsidenten italiano die
Kontrolle der Politik durch die Gerichte
Schwächen heute kam zu den
Massenprotesten noch ein Generalstreik
inzwischen hat die Regierung reagiert
sie verschiebt ihre Form Michael
Beverungen
im Proteste Demonstrierenden klingt fast
schon Jubel mit doch dafür ist es noch
zu früh die sogenannte Justizreform der
versucht die Gewaltenteilung zu
schwächen ist verschoben aber noch nicht
von Tisch das wissen auch die
zehntausenden auf den Straßen von Tel
Aviv und im ganzen Land wir
demonstrieren schon lange nicht mehr nur
gegen die neuen Gesetze wir wollen dass
diese gesamte wahnsinnige Regierung ihre
Arbeit niederlegt diesen Wahnsinn zum
Ende bringt damit das Volk wieder eins
wird es geht schon lange nicht mehr nur
um die Reform
nachdem der Tanja und den
Verteidigungsminister entlassen hatte
stand er selbst vor einer
Regierungskrise galant und weitere
Liquid Mitglieder hatten einen Stopp der
Reform gefordert umgekehrt rote für
diesen Fall der rechtsextreme Minister
Benedikt tritt doch der verkündete am
Abend selbst die Reform werde ausgesetzt
für Ruhe im Land wird das kaum Sorgen
denn auch die Gewerkschaften erhöhen den
Druck und rufen zum Generalstreik auf
wir alle Arbeitgeber und Arbeitnehmer im
Staate Israel in seiner ganzen Länge und
Breite lasst uns die Justizreform
stoppen stoppt den Wahnsinn
viele Branchen wollen dem Aufruf folgen
ob das Aussetzen der Reform daran etwas
ändert ist offen
in diesen Minuten äußert sich
Ministerpräsident Netanyahu zu der
Verschiebung der Justizreform Michael
Beverungen in Tel Aviv was wissen sie
schon
ja die zigmal im Laufe des Tages
verschobene Pressekonferenz hat jetzt in
diesen Minuten bekommen netanjo hat noch
nicht so viel gesagt aber er spricht von
einer salomonischen Entscheidung und
meint offenbar damit den Kompromiss mit
itama Ben Gewehr der tritt nicht zurück
sondern stimmt der Verschiebung der
Reform zu dafür bekommt er so etwas wie
eine eigene Nationalgarde eine
militärische Truppe für den Einsatz
Investoren an Land was genau damit
gemeint ist Wissen auch noch hier die
meisten Menschen nicht ich glaube netter
Jahr hat vor allem versucht sich Zeit zu
verschaffen mit diesem Kompromiss ob es
das auch für Israel für den Streit auf
den Straßen bedeutet das sage ich zu
bezweifeln es ist nur eine Atempause
viel ändern wird sich nicht wir haben es
gehört die Demonstrationen werden
wahrscheinlich weitergehen aber es wird
jetzt zumindest erstmal Gespräche mit
der Opposition über diese Justizreform
geben
Michael Beverungen live aus Tel Aviv
danke schön
jetzt der Blick in die Ukraine vor knapp
einem Jahr konnten Soldaten im Osten des
Landes einige Ortschaften von russischen
Besatzern zurückerobern eine davon war
Stari Seite rund 45 km von der Stadt
hakif entfernt seitdem sind ein paar 100
Einwohner zurückgekehrt wie es ihnen
dort geht zeigt eine Brille
ohne humanitäre Hilfe geht es einfach
nicht in stariseite ukrainische
freiwillige verteilen Kisten den Inhalt
kennen die Menschen oft nicht sie
brauchen einfach alles weil ihnen nichts
mehr geblieben ist
wir sind sehr dankbar das entdecken die
fehlen uns weil unsere Häuser entweder
feucht sind oder ist sie gar nicht mehr
gibt eventuell gibt es auch Geschirr
ehrlich gesagt brauche ich alles bei mir
ist nichts mehr da das große Loch im
Haus das war meine Wohnung ich habe nur
noch einen Schlüssel
bis Ende April was da recyte von den
Russen besetzt der Ort ist zu 80%
zerstört früher haben hier mal 4.500
Menschen gewohnt ein paar hundert sind
wieder zurückgekommen reparieren die
Kriegsschäden das Rote Kreuz hat uns im
Herbst 27 LKW mit Baumaterial gebracht
wir haben die Häuser abgedeckt alles was
nicht abgedeckt wurde ist endgültig
zerstört
auch die Brücke über den Stausee ist
beschädigt nur zu Fuß kommt man rüber es
ist der einzige Weg in die Ortsteile die
am anderen Ufer liegen aber der Krieg
ist immer noch nah
die Front ist nur 15 Kilometer entfernt
immer wieder ist starker
Artilleriebeschuss zu hören die Sorge
ist groß dass die Russen nach der
recytev zurückkehren könnten
eine neue russische Offensive eine neue
Besatzung das glauben viele Menschen in
Star recytev wäre das Ende ihres Ortes
im mittelmeerwagen derzeit so viele
Migranten wie lange nicht die
gefährliche Überfahrt in Richtung
Italien allein in der Nacht erreichten
rund 650 Männer die kalabrische Küste am
Wochenende waren nach Angaben aus Rom
mehr als 5.500 Menschen angekommen seit
Januar sollen es knapp 27.000 gewesen
sein das sind mehr als viermal so viele
wie im gleichen Zeitraum vor einem Jahr
fast alle Flüchtlinge stammen aus Afrika
oder dem Mittleren Osten
Erleichterung bei Galeria Karstadt
Kaufhof die Lieferanten Banker Vermieter
und andere Gläubiger stimmten heute dem
Rettungsplan zu das bedeutet zwar dass
etliche der zuletzt noch 129 Warenhäuser
schließen und tausende Jobs abgebaut
werden aber für die anderen geht es eben
weiter Notar Becker hat Details
die Gläubiger verzichteten heute in
Essen auf Forderungen in Höhe von rund
1,4 Milliarden Euro Galeria kann
weitermachen vielleicht sogar mit mehr
Filialen als gedacht es gibt noch die
ein oder anderen Vermieter der
angekündigt haben dass dass sie auf uns
zukommen werden und unsere Forderungen
erfüllen werden deswegen hoffe ich sehr
dass wir noch das ein oder andere die
ein oder andere Filiale auf die
fortführungsliste bekommen werden
dennoch werden mindestens 3000 Stellen
abgebaut da wo es für Galeria weitergeht
soll umgebaut werden wie zum Beispiel
hier in Kassel ein modernes Ambiente
eine überarbeitete Produktpalette und
regionale Schwerpunkte sollen
Warenhäuser profitabel machen doch die
Modernisierung aller Galeria Filialen
dürfte teuer werden
die verbleibenden Filialen sind ja aus
Kunden sich der sanierungsbedürftig und
um die 82 Häuser die angebliche halten
werden sollen zu renovieren schätze ich
einen
Renovierungsaufwand von bis zu einer
Milliarde Euro wo Galeria schließt wie
hier in Duisburg müssen Kommunen nun
andere Konzepte entwickeln wie zum
Beispiel das linden-karree in
Gelsenkirchen im ehemaligen Kaufhaus
Althoff gibt es nun Dienstleister
Einzelhändler und Wohnungen kein
Nachteil für die Fußgängerzone
und jetzt Fußball die Nationalmannschaft
trifft morgen in Köln auf Belgien ja und
da sitzt Bundestrainer Hansi Flick auf
den Erfolg gegen Peru wenn 2:0 Sieg am
Samstag hatte sich die neue Doppelspitze
im Sturm ja echt bezahlt gemacht die
wird auch morgen geben und einige
verletzungsbedingte Veränderung
mehr Licht als Schatten beim Training
der DFB-Elf in Frankfurt sehen bildlich
für die aktuelle Stimmung Samstag der
Sieg gegen Peru im neuen System mit
Füllkrug ein neuer Führungsspieler der
Hoffnung weckt auf bessere
Chancenverwertung in der Zukunft haben
sie fliegt zufrieden auch wenn mit
Schlotterbeck und Herbert zwei wichtige
stützenausfallen es muss und wird weiter
getestet werden
also so dass das natürlich für Kai und
ähm für Nico Thilo Kehrer wird wird in
der Innenverteidigung spielen und sehr
knapp auf dem Kaiser seiner Position
spielen
Belastungsprobe für gnabry und kehre und
das gesamte DFB-Team gegen eine
belgische Mannschaft mit einem alten
bekannten deutschen alles zu weil ja
junge Gesichter schon aber ja ist
einfach eine Top Nation mit Topspieler
noch geht's zu arbeiten an den großen
und kleinen Dingen beim DFB um die
dunklen Wolken vollständig zu vertreiben
zum Ocean Race eine der härtesten
segelregaten überhaupt einmal um die
ganze Welt auf der dritten Etappe nimmt
Skipper Boris Herrmann mit seinem Team
malizia Kurs auf Kap Horn und liegt
derzeit in Führung aber die
Herausforderung die sind groß
Boris hermann hat sein Boot extra für
die ganz schwere See konstruieren lassen
vor allem heute am berüchtigten Kap Horn
unterhalb von Thiele muss es sich
beweisen die malizia liegt in Führung es
ist ein wahnsinnsritt 5 Boote Gewalt die
Gewinde das Boot stabil zu halten
schwierig das bekam die 26-Jährige
Rosalie kolber aus Hermanns Team hart zu
spüren aus der Koje geschleudert schlug
sie mit dem Kopf auf und liegt mit einer
Gehirnerschütterung flach
jetzt am Tag 28 braucht es einen
ausgeschlafenen Geist doch mit dem
Schlafen ist das so eine Sache an Bord
mit Drohnen Bildern und navigation will
das Team die Konkurrenz weiter hinter
sich lassen und kann positiv in Richtung
Atlantik blicken mit seinem Kapitän
das letzte Stück der dritten Etappe des
Ocean Race kann kommen und das Ziel etwa
am ersten April
und von da aus sind es dann etwa noch so
12.000 Seemeilen bis zum Ziel Genua
Wahnsinn doch vielen Dank und zum
Schluss noch was poetisches oder
ärgerliches wie man es nimmt diese Zeit
des Übergangs wenn Winter und Frühling
miteinander rangeln
ärgerlich wie hier im Erzgebirge musste
manche Schneeschaufel noch mal ran
poetisch die Frühlingsblumen hielten
tapfer dagegen und auch den Ostereiern
stehen die weißen Mützen eigentlich ganz
gut
und auch die kommende Nacht bringt
Schneeglätte und Schauer mehr dazu hat
gleich Katja horneffer Marietta Slomka
begrüßt sie im heute journal um viertel
vor zehn hier übernimmt morgen Jana
pareigis ich danke Ihnen für Ihr
Interesse und wünsche eine gute Zeit bis
bald auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten Abend da ist es zum Beginn der
Woche doch noch mal richtig winterlich
geworden zwischen diesem Tief über
Osteuropa und dem hoch über der Biskaya
da kam noch mal richtig kalte Luft von
Norden heran und zu lagen heute die
Höchsttemperaturen an der Ostsee nur bei
8 Grad und heute Nacht wird es noch mal
häufig frostig mit Werten von 0 bis -5
Grad und frostfrei bleibt es eigentlich
nur ganz im Nordwesten das liegt dort
auch am auflandigen Wind von der Nordsee
es gibt heute Nacht noch kräftige
Schneeregen und Schneeschauer es wird
also rutschig auf den Straßen besonders
in den Mittelgebirgen unterm Alpenrand
es kann an der Ostsee auch noch mal für
ein Gewitter reichen und morgen geht's
weitere Schneeregen und Schneeschauer in
diesem Band ungefähr von der Elbmündung
bis zur Donau jedenfalls am Vormittag
dann lassen diese Regen und Schneefälle
nach richtig freundlich wird es an der
Ostsee mit viel Sonnenschein im Westen
sitzt dagegen erstmal freundlich aus
dann werden die Wolken am Nachmittag
dort dich dabei Westwind die
Temperaturen liegen morgen bei 4 Grad in
den östlichen Mittelgebirge und elf Grad
am Oberrhein und der Mittwoch wird noch
ganz freundlich aber dann wird deutlich
wechselhafter allerdings wird es in den
nächsten Tagen auch wieder merklich
milder bei 8 bis 18 Grad guten Abend